wow to be transported to 2006 where Tom
and Katie are happily in love and I
don't have depression black mirror's
fourth installment this season totally
caught me off guard and warned me never
to go on a drug-induced Bender in the
Czechoslovakian Countryside in this
video we'll be taking a look at Maisie
day it's ending and all the cool Black
Mirror Easter eggs throughout so pack
some silver bullets we have some
celebrities to shoot meet Bo at Down and
Out paparazza staking out famous Sea of
Tranquility star Justin camley you may
remember Sea of Tranquility as being one
of black mirror's recurring Easter eggs
not only can it be found on streamberry
from episode 1's Joan is awful but four
other episodes in national anthem the
special effects expert hired to fake the
Prime Minister shagging a pig says he
worked on it there's nosedive where a
few characters chat about attending
Tranquility con and in Smithereens where
hashtag Sea of Tranquility reboot is
trending then there's Rachel Jack and
Ashley too where a reporter talks about
it getting a reboot Bo is an interesting
name having its origin from Scandinavia
meaning to live Beau is the only
Survivor in this tale and it also
conjures images of Little Bo Peep a
Shepherd protecting her flock from
wolves but when Justin finds that Bo has
been taking pics of him cheating on his
girlfriend with a man he says two really
interesting lines the first you're
killing me which foreshadows him killing
himself and the second calling Bo a
[__] animal one of the big questions
this episode asks who is the real animal
the werewolf that will end up stalking
our characters or the characters
themselves it's your classic the humans
were the monsters after all and these
Paparazzi are absolute vile human beings
taking upskirt shots of celebrities
stalking them outside their homes and
even photographing them when they're
clearly in a state of physical duress
bonus points if you caught the Paw
Prince Outside The Quagmire nightclub
Quagmire also being the name of the sexy
Club in San Junipero but it's it's not
just the paparazzi who are vile famous
celebrity Maisie day runs over someone
in an apparent hit and run or at least
that's what we're led to believe in her
flashbacks we'll see that she actually
stopped to check up on the man but upon
investigating discovered it was a
werewolf it's implied that she was
bitten and became one herself possibly
Through Blood since in the previous
scene we saw her break a glass of wine
and cut her finger and near the end of
the episode we see that same finger
reaching for the wolf I also think it's
ironic that her last name is day
considering what happens to her at night
while reading up on Maisie we learned
that she starred in something called the
ever wish Saga it made me think of The
Twilight Saga which coincidentally
features werewolves and the same song
supermassive black hole which plays in
the car when Maisie hits the wolf after
Justin's death Beau quits the paparazzi
feeling that she played a role in his
death she takes up a job at Yorkie's
coffee the same place Joan got her
coffee from in Joni's awful Yorkie is
coincidentally the name of the main
character in San Junipero but Beau is
brought back into the job when she hears
that shots of Maisie who hasn't been
seen in weeks are selling for 30k so she
stalks the house of a producer friend
where Macy's apparently staying and
noticed the full moon in the top right
and now that I see this scene in
retrospect it's clear this wasn't a
drug-fueled rage but rather her
transforming into a werewolf this has
resulted in her calling in doctor to the
Stars Dimitri babic whose Eastern
European background may give him
specific insight into what happened in
the Czech Republic he knows that she is
a werewolf organizing the private
location up at Cedarwood Retreat
chaining her body to the ground and even
providing goats for the hungry creature
to eat beau's search for Maisie ends up
with maisie's driver slashing her car
tires and leaving her abandoned at the
Emerald Pines Diner but his luck would
have it she's informed that a famous
celebrity has booked out the entire
Cedarwood Retreat nearby fine that's
gotta be where Maisie is so she calls
fellow paparazzo Hector to bring his
motorcycle up and the two head over to
the retreat what Hector doesn't know is
that witty and Duke placed a tracker on
his bike and now are in on the photos
too this is going to be a massive payday
approaching the cabin they see that
Maisie is chained up and it seems Beau
is the only ones concerned for her
safety while the others are more focused
on taking pictures we'll see her grab a
rock from this oddly placed stack but
it's never mentioned if this is part of
some sort of voodoo Dimitri has set up
or if the writers just needed a way for
them to gain access to the cabin as Beau
clamors to free Maisie the clouds give
way revealing the moon and transforming
the celebrity into a bloodthirsty
werewolf witty is the first to go with
Duke soon to follow to show just how
cruel these characters are instead of
helping Duke Hector steals his camera
when he's stuck because he knows how
much all those photos will be worth but
when Hector make their way back to the
diner were an officer by the name of
Rittman finishes a pecan pie he has the
same last name as Colin Rittman from
bandersnatch it doesn't take long for
the werewolf to descend upon the diner
absolutely massacring its patrons and up
until the very end Hector is still
taking photographs he may be a piece of
[__] but damn is he committed to the job
Bo gives the werewolf a killer blow
transforming it back to Maisie who asked
to be shot she'll get what she asked for
just not in the way she was hoping for
as Beau photographs her killing herself
Beau has become the greatest monster of
all the void of any Humanity as she
takes in maisie's last moments for her
own personal gain but let me know what
you thought about Maisie day do
Paparazzi deserve to be mauled to death
by vicious werewolves let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember and how the
consequences don't under game
[Music]